Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test.
What I'm gonna do is take
each of your weapons,
and I'm gonna beat
them repeatedly
and viciously into different
points of this shield.
Ashe, you're up first.
How you feeling?
- Good.
Let's do it.
All right.
[music playing]
[grunting]
[chuckles]
Ashe, aside from
the obvious, you'd
have a very nice weapon here.
The handle has got
a good grip to it.
I was able to get some
really heavy duty, good,
penetrating strikes in there.
But obviously, we
have a problem.
It broke.
When you put your
little spike in here,
these corners here are sharp.
So even though it looks
like a very good heat treat,
you got a stress fracture
in there somewhere.
All that strength and
pressure came down that blade
and snapped that off
right on that joint.
[grunting]
Ashe, your blade has suffered
a catastrophic failure,
and cannot continue
with testing.
But that doesn't mean that
you're out of this competition.
Levi, your blade needs
to survive at least
nine strikes on this shield.
Are you ready?
Indeed, sir.
Ashe, are you ready?
Oh, yeah.
Jay Nielsen, are you ready?
Let's do this, gents.
Will tells me my blade has to
make it through nine strikes.
I'm hoping and praying that
it's going to last longer.
[grunting]
[clanking]
[groaning]
Bladesmiths, this sengese is
incredibly difficult to make.
And both of you made
very deadly weapons.
However, you both had
problems in our strength test.
Ashe, your blade failed
after nine strikes.
Levi, unfortunately,
your blade suffered
a catastrophic failure
on the first strike
against that shield.
And for that reason,
I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
I definitely proved
what I came to prove.
I wanted to be
able to push myself
beyond my regular limits.
Good job, dude.
Good job.
My family at
home is definitely
gonna be proud of me.
And I'm taking home skills
and knowledge that I
didn't have before I came here.
And that's definitely
a win for me.